from everyone to our Thursday
informatics conference and I'm pleased
to introduce our speaker dr. Michael
Chen who is doing he came by to visit me
and telling me about some interesting
work that he's doing so I said why don't
you come give a talk and so that's what
he's doing today and it's also
interesting coming on the heels some of
you know I spent the last few days at
the hims meeting the big industry trade
conference and in fact I could actually
still be down there today but I wanted
to come back for this and I think the
world is kind of coming around to the
vision that we're going to hear today of
patient centered patient controlled data
one of the speaker's was actually the
new CMS administrator so CMS the payer
for Medicare and there they actually
announced well they didn't give much
details but they announced this new my
healthy data initiative that will enable
people to presumably get better access
to their data and and share it with
other healthcare providers and and
others and and of course there's these
other high-profile projects like the
Apple being able to download your epic
data into your Apple health app anyways
so it gives me great pleasure to
introduce dr. Chen who is actually a
practicing family physician here in
Portland works at Portland clinic and
also Palladino health maybe he'll tell
us a little bit about that I don't know
real lot about it but he also spends his
time developing software with the
orientation of this patient center
approach so rather than I try to explain
it I'm going to turn it over to him
there are as we stream this there are
people out there listening if anyone has
a question just tweet it with the
hashtag team ice comm DM IC e conf and
I'll kind of keep an eye on it and any
of you who have questions can ask as
well so take it away
sorry so so I'm a family physician
working at palutena health and the
portland clinic and palutena health is a
direct primary care clinic that serves
patients where patients pay a monthly
membership fee we don't build insurance
so it's a different type of a primary
care one where we have more ability to
spend more time with our patients manage
patients not just in clinic that in
clinic encounters but also through
patient portals and phone consults
without having to deal with billing and
stuff like that so that's a little bit
about what I do currently I also happen
to work and on a volunteer basis on an
open source electronic health record
project that that deals with this
patient centered longitudinal health
records so I'll kind of go through the
overview and some of the questions that
I was thinking about when I was trying
to figure this out and I worked with I
work with another physician who is based
in Massachusetts his name is dr. Adrian
Gropper he's well known in health IT
circles in terms of patient privacy
concerns he also used to run an open
source medical imaging or radiology
imaging service and so I've been working
alongside with him in terms of open
standards and open sourcing these ideas
and I'm going to be talking about today
I'll feel free to ask questions and I'll
hopefully we'll get to answer most of
them at the end of the session but if
you have any questions along the way
please let me know so I'm going to talk
about today some of the challenges that
we're facing today and some T
technologies that dr. Hirsch kind of
hinted at things like fire I don't know
if you guys are know know about fire and
including some things like block chain
which is part of this component if you
will this project and I'm going to talk
about the proposed solution that we are
making and then opportunities for
questions and discussion so firstly I
want to talk about the challenges so I
want you guys to imagine being as a
patient you know how do you as a patient
make sure that your records are up to
date for in front of the physician that
you're seeing now if you're stuck if
you're in one institution and everyone's
on the same system that's great but
there's also a part of quite a few
patients that see physicians from
different groups and what if they don't
have epoch what if they don't even have
any HR how do they make sure that these
records are are up-to-date and current
so that's one of the key questions and
even today even though even though
organizations are doing a much better
job of coordinating care technology wise
we still there's a big gap that that we
we must acknowledge so in terms of
different specialists and different
needs you know in terms of what's what
belongs on the health record and what
gets filtered out those are things that
are some challenges too because it's not
like a one-size-fits-all type of
electronic health record system that
we're talking about and then lastly we
also want to talk about just consumer
health apps or wearables you know where
does that data going is it going to the
physician is the physician get to see it
are they utilizing are they ignoring it
where does that go and where does that
fit in from a patient perspective who is
wanting to be engaged and currently
right now there really isn't a good
answer of where those with that data is
going to and then lastly I wanted to
also talk about patient privacy and
consent now we know about HIPAA and
HIPAA is an agreement that a patient
signs with an organization that they are
working with or a clinic but we also are
acknowledging that there aren't gaps in
terms of where does that data go you
know once it's in the what's in the the
organization what if there's another
third party that wants to get
non-identified healthcare
where does that go what you know what
are the provisions for that and you know
some of those are theoretical but some
of them are our concerns and concerns in
terms of security too sir in terms of
organizations having a large amount of
patient data and hacking and the
vulnerability of that data and then
lastly who owns the patient's health
care data is it the patient is the
organization and so those are some of
the things that were that I wanted to
talk about here and right now I think in
my opinion patients are kind of
spectators of their health care data
they some of them take it upon
themselves that they or they organize or
they aggregate their health care data on
their own but a lot of work and it may
or may not be accurate either but and so
but I think currently right now I
believe patients are still kind of out
on the fringe if you will in terms of
how they really own or have control over
their healthcare data and then from a
physician standpoint some of the
challenges that we acknowledge or know
about is that there's physicians who are
dissatisfied with user interfaces with
the hrs certainly some EHRs are better
than others but there is a wide gamut of
satisfaction or dissatisfaction of user
interfaces and how do they how do they
have a voice in terms of improving their
workflow and then we talked a little bit
about how to physicians communicate with
other physicians within the organization
or outside of their organization and
this is what we you know talk about
interoperability and the lack thereof
between certain systems with others and
then there was a point of care decision
support some EHRs are do better than
others but some of them don't have it at
all and how do we make the technology
that we have useful for the physician
and then also for the patient as well I
think there's there are some
opportunities there that that are not
really
they're not really being utilized at
this point and then we talked a little
bit about this before in terms of data
security database breaches ransomware
and then the whole idea of health
information exchanges and challenges
with that so patient matching is the
biggest one that where a lot of the
exchanges are having issues with then
data integrity whether you know one
organization has one set of data the
other another organization has slightly
different data which one is the right
one where's the patient involved in that
decision-making or there a care
physician de-identified patient data and
how does that get to be useful or not
useful for the patient of in terms of
patient feedback and then things like
vendor lock in certain organizations
have you spent large amounts of money on
their EHR systems because of Meaningful
Use and where did they you know what are
their options of down the future as
technology becomes it evolves and so
that's so that's also another concern
and then lastly walled garden technology
and silos where EHRs are kind of trying
to encourage other clients to use their
saving HR but still the other you know
of another client uses a different EHR
that are they talking to each other so
now I'm going to talk a little bit about
some current technologies that exist
right now and and some things that kind
of convert have converged as you if you
will that have led to our ideas with
this project that I'm going to be
talking about so one of them is
something called OAuth 2 I don't know if
you guys are familiar with that but that
is something that for instance Google
when you sign on to Gmail they can
connect to another app that uses Google
for their sign-on authentication and
basically that technology allows you to
just remember what password which is the
Google password to get on to various
different sites if another site utilizes
that now we've also are seeing a huge
explosion in cloud
computing and virtual machines and
technologies such as docker that are
that are able to deploy micro servers if
you will that utilize very low resources
operate using linux as an operating
system that primarily work functions as
a web server and then blockchain the big
B word that everyone talks about that's
new and how does that fit in with
healthcare and so for us what we're
going to be talking about with
blockchain is how blockchain can be used
for self sovereign identity I don't know
you guys don't know what that is but
essentially it's essentially a situation
where you as a person can present
yourself as an identity without having a
federated or an organization saying and
vouch for you essentially you have
basically have claims if you will from
different organizations and if there's a
match for all these claims then a
service or a login or a service can log
you in without needing something like
like a some other client like Google for
instance being your Authenticator and
then we're also talking about using
blockchain as a way of a public ledger
and that's one of the big things about
blockchain is the establishment of trust
amongst parties that normally may not
have had a relationship with each other
but to establish trust that the
blockchain is essentially a public
ledger that says that this particular
transaction occurred at this particular
time and it's not reputable now and and
so essentially we're talking about
blockchain as a way to notarize on
certain transactions for instance in
this project that we're going to be
talking about we're going to use the
example of writing a prescription a
physician writing a prescription and
then also now with the emergence of
certain open standards so fire I talked
about earlier we're also using something
called you um a or you OMA which is user
managed access which is essentially an
offshoot of OAuth 2
and in a workgroup that is currently
that I am dr. cropper are part of that
is working on setting certain open
standards if you will of these types of
technology transactions and then of
course using open source technology as a
way to encourage peer review of the code
for this patient-centered health
longitudinal health record so any
questions before I proceed I know there
was a lot of stuff there but hopefully
that that makes sense so what I'm
proposing today is a situation where
we're talking about a distributed
network model so rather than a
centralized network model where let's
say an organization like OHSU has their
epic records and that's essentially a
centralized record where everybody else
kind of feeds in data into epic what
we're proposing is a distributed network
model where we have what we call patient
containers so essentially a web server
that's in the cloud that's all owned and
operated by the patient and and we call
this hie of one which is the think is
over here that has information to the
code at the github site and what we're
talking about here in more detail and so
what makes hie of one unique is that
it's actually two integrated components
one of them is an EHR that has been
designed and engineered as a single
patient EHR so rather than while we
think of EHRs now as an EHR that serves
thousands or millions of patients
basically this EHR only has one patient
and we have many potentially many
providers that feed in or feed data into
this patient health a patient health
electronic health record system and then
we have something the second component
being the authorization server which
functions as an oauth2
server functions as an uma server and
sets policies that are dictated by the
patient when they launch their launch
there
their container about who has access and
who has the ability to write or read
their health record information and then
both of them utilize blockchain
technology and certain operations for
authentication for notarization for
instance so this each our component I
talked a little bit about that already
kind of jumped the gun the HR that is
being used for this project is called
nosh which was this is how I got
involved in the project because that was
the program that I created back in 2009
when I ran I had a solo practice back
then and I created an open-source
electronic health record that's
web-based and that can be utilized both
on desktops and smartphones and tablets
and and so that was one of the that
project basically got converted if you
will into this patient-centered health
record because it had an existing
patient portal as a part of this program
the EHRs device agnostic meaning like it
doesn't matter if you have a Windows
computer a Mac computer or a tablet you
can utilize this e jar from any device
and it was designed from the get-go from
the foundation to be able to process and
produce fire transactions and this is
the key part of what makes this EHR this
this patient-centered health record to
be able to communicate from itself to
other organizations and it already has
ways to likewise mention before with the
patient portal has secured secure as a
secure communication component for
patient and physician communication and
the EHR also generates automatic
notifications to authorized physicians
for any changes or updates to the
patient health record now with the
authorization server again it's also
web-based its device agnostic it works
as a single sign-on entity like I
mentioned before and therefore the
patient does not need to remember
different sign ons to get to their EHR
and their authorization server and the
authorization server allows patient
physicians to use the self sovereign
identity identity project which that
utilizes blockchain which is a separate
project from us but we're using it as a
test vehicle call you port and
theoretically a physician could with
their smartphone if they have their you
port app installed essentially they can
go to these services and if they have
enough claims to say okay I have an NPI
number I'm a medical automatical
licensed in the state of Oregon then a
physician could theoretically introduce
themselves to a patient's authorization
server and if the patient has already
dictated policies saying any physician
in the United States that has an NPI
number that has a valid medical license
from any of the 50 states could log in
to my system even though I've never sit
stated specifically this particular
doctor has to go ahead now they could
but they could also set a default policy
that's based on these claims and that
way you know for if you can imagine if
is a patient that is out of town they
get injured they go to an ER and they
could theoretically this ER physician
could theoretically get to their health
records from OHSU and from the primary
care doctor from the Portland Clinic
without having to go through the whole
HIPAA security issue because essentially
the patient has their own HIPPA secured
agent which is this authorization server
so the coupled EHR that goes with this
authorization server becomes the first
what we call resource server meaning the
resources are the patient the patient
data now there could be variety of
different resources like OHSU or
different organizations that pull into
this as the patient aggregates and one
of the things that we were able to
demonstrate in our HIV of one system
from the get-go was the way to ability
the ability to connect to an epic
institution because I think Reese
they put out something called open epic
which is a fire service where if they
have though if a person or patient has
the right authentication to their my
chart for instance they can actually
pull in data through fire into whatever
app that the patient has set up and in
this particular case we're using our
patient authorization server as that app
and we were able to successfully pull in
data if you have a my chart account to
epic and so we know that that works and
we're also working with Cerner currently
right now through their implementation
because each of them each of them are
slightly different but in terms of how
much they're willing to open but certain
resources like medications problem lists
allergies those are all some of the
basic ones that we were able to pull in
from epic I talked about certain things
like default policy is that a patient
can set up for their authorization
service so they don't have to do the
work of authorizing each and every
single physician if they choose to so so
in terms of the blockchain component one
of the key things that our project is
really adamant about is that we don't
actually store any patient health
information on the blockchain so for
example this whole notarization idea
that we talked about with this patient
prescription what we are utilizing in
our demonstration is that lets say a
physician utilizes the the EHR that the
patient is serving up there on their
patient health record and the physician
writes a prescription for lyse interpret
it explains it saves it or when he signs
it basically a fire document which is a
JSON text file essentially becomes
hashed and that particular document has
basically the you know the requisites of
all the information that needs to be on
the prescription or on the prescription
in the fire format
and then that gets hashed and then that
hash gets sent over to the blockchain
that basically has says says that this
position of this user signed a
prescription at this particular time
with this document hash so let's say the
patient has this prescription on their
EHR they're giving it to a pharmacy and
say hey I have this prescription
electronically that was signed by this
position and then the pharmacy could
then use an app that looks up this on
the blockchain this public ledger and
says okay this fire document that's in
you know in English or you can kind of
see it in English but human readable but
then they hash it or they compare that
hash of that document to what's on the
blockchain and then if it matches or the
passion matches then it means that that
that prescription is is legitimate as
legitimate and it's not been tampered
with so you know so one of the people
was a lot of people have asked well how
can you know how can you prevent certain
orders or prescriptions from not being
tampered by the patient if the patient
owns and controls their health record
well this is exactly what we're using
blockchain for is this notarization
digital notarization function and this
hash actually is not human readable so
there's no patient health information
that's residing on the blockchain it
doesn't say who the prescription is for
or who who signed it literally on that
hash it so the only and so so agencies
like the pharmacy in this particular
example would be establishing or
confirming trust with the prescription
that the physician generated and that
the patient presents so this three-way
relationship is is yeah absolutely
you know because because that you know I
think that's a concern that a lot of
people have is you know the integrity of
records whether they're altered by
patients or anyone else so so basically
you're creating a hash of this
prescription that lives somewhere else
and then some when a patient presents
with it then
it's they have to confirm that or begins
that half that's right that actually
seems like a pretty good use case for
blockchain or other technologies that
would do that sort of thing
that's correct right and so yeah so the
only thing associated with a particular
entity like a patient or a pharmacy is
the timestamp right so there's a
timestamp and the document hash that
goes with that timestamp that signifies
a particular transaction took place
and I already went through this about in
terms of self sovereign identification
which also uses blockchain technology
I'm using a smartphone with touch ID so
that's the other part of it that we
would use watching but there and then
also for the signing mechanism that I
talked about again with that identity
being verified by the physician saying
okay I'm a physician and I can sign this
prescription of that gets integrated as
a part of the blockchain transaction
that gets saved so yep I kind of went
through that verbally any questions
about the blockchain component with this
EHR so in terms of benefits that we're
proposing we believe that this type of
proposal will not necessarily alter or
replace existing institutional EHRs what
we're proposing that this is something
that works in adjunct to existing
technologies but to help solve this
interoperability problem as well as a
paid as well as the patient ownership of
their healthcare data problem and
security which theoretically then
potentially reduces redundancy of tests
for instance errors medical errors and
improving communications between the
patients and physicians and then this
also is a benefit for those providers
that are in their own independent
practices that either don't have any HR
or they're not happy with your EHR
they'd rather use the patient-centered
health record EHR they can choose to do
either one and because of fire you know
they can you know a physician now works
at OHSU doesn't like their epic system
they can enter something on the patient
health record which then it was shuttled
out information back when the patient's
when he signs that note to the epoch to
epoch in theory that is you know using
fire would be a way to communicate or to
to send data for from one container to
the institution and then what we
envision is that we're creating a whole
new application ecosystem where health
apps are no longer needing multiple
agreements with either a specific
institution or variety of institutions
or EHRs and that's one of the challenges
today if you're a health app provider or
developer that they have to go through
these different channels to be able to
have access to a patient or patient
population for for whatever usage that
they're needing they can actually go
through these patient containers and the
patients would then give the
authorization for their data to be
released if they choose to to these to
these health apps and it will be no
longer kind of this kind of this second
or this layer of you know the health app
having a an agreement with an agency but
the patient has no say necessarily where
their data is going to once that
agreement is set and then likewise we
can envision here where a health app
could potentially get real-time feedback
of the patient data which could be a
huge assistance in terms of both
artificial intelligence and machine
learning and utilizing data in terms of
predicting certain types of disease
models or dis R or being able to provide
health activity related feedback for the
patient and then we're also utilizing
the system we're encouraging the usage
of these patient data for to include
things like social determinants of
health that are starting to be talked
about in certain health IT circles right
now and what we believe is that by
having patients have more ownership of
their data this will further facilitate
improvement of tracking these social
determinants of
for instance things like family history
and social history physical activity as
and as being certain examples of that
and so with the HR U of 1 we've got
certain we've got two pilot projects
that we're currently are in the works of
that are currently in the works one of
them is based in Austin Texas that is an
hie that right now doesn't have a fully
functioning hie and they wanted
something different and that's why and
when they heard about our project they
wanted to include us in terms of
facilitating a 300 group 300 physician
group patient population that's served
by the Texas Medicaid population yeah
yeah so hie is health information
exchange and the health information
exchange was born out of this idea of
trying to solve the interoperability
problem where you know an institution
has one EHR a different institution as a
different EHR how do they pull together
the information so that eventually
hopefully the patient will have a
complete record irregardless of the
irregardless of the institution but
again we talked about how there's
challenges with things like patient
matching and a lot of them are
struggling right now because of the lack
of interoperability between existing EHR
systems end because patients really
don't have much of a say in terms of how
their patient is or their data is
up-to-date or correct or or owned if you
will by the patient by once the hie has
integrated or conglomerated the
different patient data for that one
patient so hopefully that makes sense
and that's why we called our project HR
you have one so instead of an hie either
serves thousands of patients we're
talking about an hie that serves only
one patient so we're looking at it from
a completely different angle
and then our second pilot project that
we're also working with is in awesome
Atlanta Georgia and primarily working
with the homeless population trying to
figure out how to utilize some of the
self sovereign identification they have
a way to doing my biometric and then
digital health digital or touch ID as a
way to signify okay this patient even if
this patient doesn't have any
identification with them in terms of
paper identification how do they make
sure that that that patient has a viable
health record that stands different
institutions wherever they may be or
where they go and so that's so we're
also building a pilot project with our
system there as well and so we're all
you know part of what I'm talking when I
when I spoke with dr. Hirsh was since I
was based out of Portland I thought hey
you know this was an opportunity to have
people that are that know about and you
know that know about this project to be
a part of being able to think of some
ideas of how we can show or you to
utilize specific patient populations to
see the utility in the usage of this
particular system ideally we like every
patient to be able to have this but we
know that to show viability and whether
it actually works we want to try to make
sure that we can demonstrate that for a
specific patient population that this
has made a difference in their care by
their physicians and that the patients
have a better ways of utilizing their
own healthcare data in the future so so
that's the end of my talk if I have a
few minutes left a little time yeah so
yeah I'm open to any questions and then
yeah it's actually not really a question
but it's it actually is in part a kind
of validation of so at the hims meeting
the other day I saw
actually some of these folks know Ricky
Bloomfield from Apple
get up and I'm actually do a demo where
you know and the next version of iOS you
know supports the the Apple health app
supports downloading fire data and so he
actually he was previously Duke and now
he's out at Apple and wherever Cupertino
River was these days and hey and he has
health records you know in at Duke and
University of North Carolina and dignity
health and in California and he actually
showed did a live demo how he and you
know he had an iPhone 10 so he did the
face ID thing too and and he he could
pick and then authorize through OAuth to
the data to come out of these epic
instances to is Apple health app which
at least that kind of demonstrated at
a-- to reside but it demonstrated that
he could contact with Epic Systems and
and pull the data in so I mean it's a so
it's not a real far-fetched idea in fact
I think as you probably know assuming we
continue meaningful use stage 3 in its
certification that will require to have
that open API so it was interesting to
see yeah and that's that's that's a very
similar thing that with our demo where
we were able to like I said if you have
a my chart account that's essentially
the two way to get in to your data that
goes through your authorization server
yeah I may have missed that but um are
you using it in your own medical
practice at the moment so my medical
practice what the portland clinic that
uses epic so they i don't utilize that
currently with my old practice i did and
so there's a number of small independent
practices that are utilizing just the
EHR component of nage
no one is currently utilizing the
patient health record
I mean essentially I mean if you once we
deploy some of these pilots I'll
probably be one of the first ones to
have my own for myself and my family but
essentially the idea is that he each
patient would then deploy their own
essentially webserver
for this and then the medical providers
can still utilize their EHR or utilize
my old my EMR essentially to be able to
interface with the patient health record
if they so choose to yes um thanks for a
great talk I was just going to follow up
on your question about populate a use
case population and the thing that
popped into mind homeless population I
think it's a great idea but also just
like kids in general where you have like
both parents or maybe grandparents are
essentially any patient right we're more
than there primarily relying on
caregivers or multiple caregivers
specifically so that you can in high
youths medical cases just so you can
actually like have I don't know you have
a better coordination and you're not
throwing right one of the things that we
talked about in our project is utilizing
an example for like cystic fibrosis and
and for kids and with this authorization
server technically a patient even a
child patient that has their own web
server basically can designate someone
else to be their proxy to set
authorization parameters and then once
they're of legal age they can choose to
revoke or change who has access or has
the ability to set policies on their
authorization server essentially you
know I totally tell other physicians
about this authorization server project
essentially this authorization server it
serves as an agent essentially that that
governs these policies so that their
healthcare data is securely getting to
the right people that the patient has
designated so
yes um another unrelated question to the
one before um so where I see that maybe
open-source EHRs could actually play a
bigger role in the future is just by
like taking what's already been invented
by other open-source EHRs and combining
them not reinventing the wheel about
everything using modular code and
thereby like just saving the time to
like reinventing it from scratch so I
was wondering looking over your github
are you do you collaborate with other
ones like open iam are there no about or
do you use things from vista or whatever
is out there or what's the relationship
is there an open source community and
what's the relationship yeah the open
source community in terms of EHRs is
unfortunately that it's it's it's it's
got its challenges in fact I was one of
the first I collaborated or I did I
worked with open EMR at the beginning
went before I decided to make my own and
a lot of what I was when I when I first
started to develop my EHR what I was
envisioning was primarily from a user
interface standpoint I was I was really
a stickler on workflow mainly because I
had my own practice and I wanted to make
sure that the EHR worked for me in terms
of how things flowed from a clinical
perspective and I found that it was hard
because open EMR was not necessarily
modular that it was hard to change one
thing without affecting everything else
and it was hard to put in request that
basically fundamentally change the
entire system it so because a lot of the
user interface challenges relates to how
the the code foundation if you will or
data based foundation really is is
structured and so that was one of the
reasons why I ended up completely you
know overhauling or creating a whole new
system
and you know I wish it didn't have to be
that way but sometimes you know those
those fundamental challenges become so
great that you just happen it's easier
to just create something new
now down future I mean I think ideally
if there
can be some increased collaboration or
movement towards where people were
different open-source projects can can
pull together resources that would be
great one of the each the HR or the the
code base that I use is based on
something called laravel which is an
open-source PHP framework which has tons
of contributors and those one of the
reasons why I decided to use that is
that it's a good jumping point for other
developers to you know utilize or add or
change or improve upon my code because
it's on a framework that's that's
familiar what I do is just adding or
conglomerating different parts of that
level the different level plugins if you
will to to create what I made so so
that's so that was one of the other
reasons why I decided to use that as as
a as a foundation for my code and the
authorization server basically utilizes
the same framework as well yes I'm
thinking about when you mentioned hae-in
the lack of patient control over the
data I really like that you know
starting from the ground up I wonder how
many coders really you know start from
this perspective of patient centered I
think that's wonderful
I'm wondering how in doing that you're
approaching a patient input on their own
record most specifically I'm thinking of
a use case of like medications let's say
medication list that's super messy you
know the stuff wasn't taken off and you
know Doc's don't have time or what you
know and that happens all the time right
and but then even something as simple as
you know which document comes from where
and are they are they in their
appropriate places right that's a great
question and one of the things that with
this patient-centered health record is
the ability to reconcile information
both from a physician our patient input
requests know like a patient says well
I'm actually taking this medication in a
certain way rather than what the
physician is prescribed or I'm not even
taking this medication at all or you
know or this other physician from a
different institution has recommended
this but
recommended this prescription or this
medication and so there's a weight in
the in this patient-centered health
record there's a way for the patients to
actually designate say hey I would like
to make an edit to this medication
because this is how I'm taking it it
doesn't it gets flagged it gets saved
but it gets flagged as it needs
reconciliation meaning that it's
something that the patient and another
physician that they're working with has
made a determination yes that is what
they're doing and so in each time that a
physician goes through it they'll see oh
there's certain things here that need to
be reconciled is this true and then once
they once they flag it or once they
approve it a physician signs off on it
then basically it shows up on the
complete list but you'll see the both
the patient and the physician will see
that there's things that need to be
reconciled and once when it's not
reckoned when it is all reconcile then
it is the up to date list if the EHR how
does that can can it communicate those
types of activities and reconciliation
type activities across the API to to the
different EHRs theoretically yes but
that's one of the challenges with how
you know the receiving end or the other
institution whether they will be how
they accept that and how do they
reconcile it in their own records
ideally we theorized that this patient
health record would be kind of the most
up to date record over time as people
start to utilize it that that would be
kind of the main tool if you will
primary database if you will then
everybody else will then eventually
synchronize to it but you know so one of
the challenges is obviously what's more
current and we have to start somewhere
and so that's why we have this
reconciliation tool as a way to start
that conversation and then eventually
this piece this patient health record
would theoretically be the kind of the
designated resource if your primary
resource that contains to act accurate
information which then will be pushed
out to other EHRs if they will receive
it but that's yeah and that's
all depends on how the other jurors will
cooperate or not about that so yes
thanks great talk he actually stole my
questions I'm curious it's not quite
clear to me how exactly you plan to
integrate this with my current EHR
systems like how are you going to be an
epoch and then access this data how is
that watching authentication how are all
those processes yeah so one of the you
know what we you know what I talked
about with this open epoch demonstration
is basically being able to start pulling
in data from different EHRs so that's
one way then to be able to push back
with depend on obviously the EHR like
epic to be able to receive that
information and integrate it in their
own system so that is something that is
outside of our control but our hope is
that once patients say hey we are
utilizing this please you know do this
for us and then that's up to them but
that's that's that that's that's kind of
how we envision where that that
interplay would go you vision may be
using some right and essentially the
authorization server like we talked
about is that fire service if you will
and the patient would log in through
there through the through their my chart
account essentially as a way to get that
data and so the patients still
ultimately have control it's not the
physician that's saying I want to
transfer this record because then the
patient you know basically the patient
is the one that controls that flow of
information going back to their
authorization server into other
institutions so actually just just so
people know that there are people
listening to the stream out there and a
question over the Twitter feed while I'm
not an expert of security technology I
believe that there are ways that savvy
hackers can find ways to work around the
hash tag or I think what she means is
the hashing mechanism or can break into
a patient container how vulnerable is
the patient record it if it exists on a
network yeah and that's that certainly
those vulnerabilities we knowledge
exists but the
the whole concept of distributed
networking it's we call it imagined
basically like a honeypot of data so you
have you know an institution that have
thousands of records a hacker could
spend you know 20 days trying to hack
this one system but the payoff is huge
they have thousands of records they can
have access to whereas if there's one
patient container that exists out in in
the cloud that only contains one patient
and a hacker goes in and maliciously
wants to get that data they could but
they really only get that one patient
data and so unless you're super
important and soon you're a celebrity
yeah maybe you're vulnerable in that
sense and we can't prevent that but in
terms of overall in terms of how we
manage security we think that the
distributed networking model works
better and it actually improves the
vulnerabilities of institutions where
basically institutions will say well I
don't even need to have my own database
anymore of thousands of patients I can
just rely on these patient health
records and again that's a you know
that's an evolution that will happen
it's not going to happen overnight but
the idea is we want to move away from
basically these data data honey pots if
you will and using this as a distributed
network model is the reasons why we
designed it or why we thought of it in
this way although if you're that one
person yeah I was actually gonna ask
another question because actually I'm
some of our students here study
bioinformatics so they do a lot of
genomics work and I always like to try
to engage them in these clinically
oriented so I mean clinically ready to
talk so in the future there may well be
a time when all of us have our genome
sequence and I suppose our genomes could
you know a pointer to out of the black
chains of the genome and and then in the
precision medicine paradigm will
increasingly learn things about our
genome that you know we're at risk for
diseases there might be you know certain
treatments for disease that might work
better because we have a certain gene
variant
I mean in a way it's kind of a form of
clinical decision support in the sense
of but distributed clinical decisions
for because the data might be out here
the rules might be somewhere else how do
you see that you see any problems with
that use case in terms of what you're
trying to produce here not necessarily
and I think this this again complements
the existing you know distribute
distribution of where the patient data
is residing because a you know how apps
where I'm just using that as a general
term or health services you know they
have a particular focus and they want to
do that focus well and they don't want
to be they'll hold all of everything and
and so I think that's that's again with
this technology it encourages that type
of development and production and it
doesn't rely on these institutions to
try to come up with these agreements
with different agencies and institutions
across the nation to get their patient
health data from mine from my chart for
instance to be able to to provide the
service that they're providing and so
things like the genome project they can
have just the part that pertains to the
patient a about this patient's genome
and that can be secure but then
everything else can reside elsewhere but
you know if someone wants to look at it
in totality for instance or primary care
physician they can see all of that in
theory in which then could make
basically terms of you know clinical
decision support much more meaningful
because we're not just getting just
pockets of data that maybe only have you
know one specific service or use case we
got we theoretically are pulling in data
from any variety of health opposite you
know they've gotten the permission by
their patient to to use and view that
information
any other questions okay
so if I understand it correctly on the
block thing will only contain the hashes
of the transaction but not the actual
content I think the main security risk
there would probably be that somebody
intentionally falsifies it potentially
by trying to like recreate like I think
the terms collision or something with
the hash with a different identity or
prescription for example that intended
so what's your take on like which
hashing algorithm to choose to minimize
that risk yeah so in terms of the
hashing algorithm that we currently is
we use shot to is basically you know
basic as a way to do it but certainly
there's different ways that we could you
know improve upon that we're just you
know what with our demo I think you know
there's definitely ways that we want to
improve that security over time as
people become more sophisticated and
potentially spoofing or hacking these
hashes but in theory though it takes a
lot of you know a lot of work for an
individual to try to do that for one
particular you know prescription you
know if we can talk about thousands of
order of thousand orders you know it
would take quite a bit of work to try to
do all of that in a malicious way but
there's always definitely room for
improvement there but we're using the
idea these hashes is basically a way
that you know the kid with these hash
matchings you can't you know it'd be
very difficult to to alter the human
readable document and say okay this is
you know what's been notarized or what's
been said on the public ledger you know
if there's no match then then the other
agency knows that that it's not valid
yeah so it just had a quick comment um
so if you if you have say
some sort of data model that's
standardized what's interesting is that
if you think about a prescription what's
in it the if you the contents it's very
vulnerable to a dictionary attack
because there are only so many
medications names tend to get used
pretty commonly and maybe have units of
measure and and you can actually think
about those like fields as like the
alphabet but one of the ways to
inoculate yourself against that is to
have a random component injected into
that and then that is shared across the
fire instance right and when you compare
hashes you can't you can't really do a
dictionary attack against a random
component one of the interesting ways
I've seen that done like a true
randomness component I think CloudFlare
one of the ways they secure is with lava
lamps right so they have a camera that
watches lava lamps and those lava lamps
are truly random because we don't
actually control anything except the on
and off switch
it's and so that that generating
randomness that way maybe one way to
harden those records that's a great
suggestion and I think that's another
reason why we like the open source way
is we know that there's a lot of people
that have great ideas about how to do
this at hardening hardened hardening and
improving the security of the system
definitely is one of our goals so thank
you time is just about up
thank you all this is actually great
conversation I this is definitely a hot
topic I'm sure dr. Chen will stick
around for a few minutes if anyone has
any questions forum thank you thank you
so much
[Applause]